how's it going bros my name is beautiful
today I have some special exciting news
you've read the title I finally finally
received the 10 million diamond play
button if you don't know YouTube who's
heading out for people with over 10
million sub channels is diamond play
button we're at 44 million so it's a
little late to the party YouTube but I
thought we'd unbox this together all
right
I'm so excited it's just some kind of
joke congratulations for surpassing
hundred thousand Congrats for a hundred
thousand subscribers are you [ __ ]
kidding me
do you think this is some kind of game
what is this [ __ ] 100k I get that
[ __ ] [ __ ] four times in a month they
announce this [ __ ] years ago four years
ago what the [ __ ] why don't you give me
440 of these yeah give one to Jimmy
Fallon
get one to diamond mine crap yeah give
one to cobble cop even idubbbz the [ __ ]
assists who the hell is that guy here
yeah get one CRB take it what you Smosh
[ __ ] [ __ ]
I ain't doing this [ __ ] anymore YouTube
I'm [ __ ] tired here I was thinking for
once my effort had been recognized I was
so happy
what's that another package
could this be
[Music]
the [ __ ] sick
it's the 1,000,001 and it's [ __ ]
broken congrats for surpassing 1 million
oh that's cool that happened years ago
give me 44 of these YouTube I had enough
of your [ __ ] I'm calling you out
right now where's my diamond play button
I'm not gonna do a [ __ ] hashtag and
make all my friends tweet at you
hashtag give Pierce his diamond play
button sent it to YouTube it's about
goddamn time
are you listening YouTube these are my
demands I want four diamond play buttons
I want them delivered by a horse I want
them smothered in glitter not too much
make it classy
I want the man delivering the packages
to be a bearded beautiful man and I want
a written apology I want you to I want
to begged apology can't believe it's
broken Jesus do job FedEx you're [ __ ]
idiots
you [ __ ] up like what am I gonna do
this is clearly trash like what am I
gonna do with it I'm legit pissed I
waited so long and I you know what I
thought okay once they announced the
diamond play button two years ago I was
like oh that's cool maybe now I'll
finally get it
all right I oppose go forth send out the
hashtag I want that [ __ ] trending on
Twitter Facebook Tumblr harass them
anywhere Instagram I don't give a [ __ ]
this ends now if I don't have my uncle
plan but I'll do something alright I'll
do something real bad YouTube you're
gonna make you're gonna regret this this
V is for you
don't make me disappoint you
not again
you